it's been quite some time since we did a
caption contest so I thought it was
about time to dig around and find a
funny picture that people might dig into
and see what they would make of it so
this is the first of what's going to be
a whole set of interesting pictures and
this is our old dog Amica here in the
park just across from our building
somebody had built a Snowman and not a
particularly attractive one as you can
see and Amica was kind of fascinated
with it so she went up to it and she's
sniffing it and you know taking a little
bite out and licking it and so I said
well see what you make of this and
everything broke down basically into two
kinds of captions at least the good ones
some were philosophical and we'll get to
those in a bit and the others focused
directly on the dog snowman interaction
so this is a really funny one I like and
he might need a little bit of background
to make sense out of this one Lamb Chop
had been struggling for work ever since
the show went off air Lamb Chop was a
puppet from when I was a kid and it was
kind of dingy and dirty looking not not
a great looking puppet and yeah this
this snowman does kind of look a bit
like Lamb Chop so that works and then we
have another one where the Snowman is
talking to Amica thanks dog for fetching
my arm sticks and you know that's what
they are they're not really great arms
either
then the next one is Amica talking to
the snowman or at least just thinking it
oh snow bear of Milwaukee what is your
wisdom and we're starting to get into
philosophy a little bit with the mention
of wisdom it does look a bit like a bear
I think because of the ears and then we
get another much more prosaic one mmm
tastes just like chicken you know people
say that all different kinds of meats
taste like chicken and so Amica would be
eating a little bit of the Snowman we
get another one the nose turned out to
be a carrot so this must be something
tasty too and with that we sort of
finish up with the
non-philosophical
captions so here is the first of the
philosophical ones heraclitus says no
man steps into the same river twice
heraclitus's dog no dog smells the same
snowman twice this dog watch and learn
heraclitus of course being famous for
having said that everything is flocks
and change and stuff like that then we
get another pre-socratic Pythagoras
stopped the Snowman from hurting the dog
because he saw in it the soul of a man
the dog bites back anyway
okay that's a bit of a stretch but it
kind of makes sense if you think about
it and you know about Pythagoras so it
you know you can't do much with nature
uh it's not going to conform to the
rules that you want to put on it then we
get this funny one the boys looking at
Socrates when he was on trial so this
would presumably be his jurors giving
Socrates the once over uh if you know
your Socrates story you know that he did
go on trial and he really muffed it
we finally get another one past Socrates
in the ancient period this one kind of
doesn't make that much sense but it's
funny nonetheless I think because of
that doggy Plato has found the form of
man doggy Aristotle will have to accept
theory of forms when form of man is
destroyed doggy maniacal laughter as I
said if you think about it it doesn't
actually make much sense but it does on
the surface and that's funny and we
finish up with this one my live reaction
at mentioning Hegel in the analytic
philosophy Department of my school
analytics don't like Hegel generally
don't read Hegel just know that Hegel is
a baddie and doesn't make any sense so
mentioning Hegel is going to get you a
one look from them and now who's giving
it is it the snow no man giving the look
or is it the dog giving the look I don't
really know myself but it's kind of a
good one so if you like these caption
contests I'll be doing more of these you
can get in on the next one you just
gotta pay attention to my community tab
so if you're a subscriber to the channel
you do want to turn on your
notifications that's the Bell so that
you'll actually see it when it pops up
and not be surprised and say oh I missed
out on this if you want to get in on it
that's what you gotta do and so stay
tuned for more of these coming down the
line